This is, this is a course, a,
a version of which I've taught almost
every year for the last 20 years.
And it evolves a little bit every a year.
I think I get a little bit better at it.
Uh,
so hopefully you'll get some
advantage from that experience.
But the idea is to try to present
to you sort of what's exciting about
biomedical engineering,
the ways that one can take science and
mathematics and apply that to improve
human health. And so, I'm not working
alone here, but we have three, uh,
teaching fellows who are affiliated with
the course, two of which are here today.
Yen, a [inaudible] is back there. Young,
raise your hand higher so
everyone can see yen. Uh,
worked on the course last year.
And so she's the senior of the teaching
fellows that are working on the course
this year. Surge Kobes is in
the back. Um, and he'll be, uh,
the second teaching fellow,
I should mention that yen is a phd student
in biomedical engineering. And, uh,
surge is an MD phd student who's getting
his phd in biomedical engineering.
The third, a teaching fellow, uh, couldn't
make it today. His name is Michael. Look,
and I'll introduce him to you, uh,
when he, uh, when he's available.
So this is the, the,
the goal, uh, for, uh,
my first lecture today to try to
answer these questions. And, uh,
you might have already noticed that,
uh,
I'm using the classes Vitu server.
Uh, so the syllabus is there.
I'm going to go over the
syllabus a little bit later,
but the syllabus is available online.
The first reading is available online
and I'll talk more about the readings at
when I get to that.
A portion of the lecture here,
and I'm going to post powerpoints
for all the lectures, hopefully, uh,
at least the day before. Uh, the lecture
takes place. So I posted this last night.
Some students find that they,
um,
benefit from printing out the powerpoints
and then they can just take their
notes along with the slides as I go. And
that's one way to do it. But, uh, but, uh,
feel free to do it, uh, whatever way works
for you. But those should be available.
So the questions I want to try to
answer it today are what is biomedical
engineering?
So why would you be interested in
spending a semester learning about this
subject? I'll talk about who will
benefit from the course and uh,
a little bit about, uh,
sort of the detail, uh, uh,
subject matter that we'll cover
in the course of this semester.
So to answer the question,
what is biomedical engineering?
We're going to spend time on that today
and we'll spend time on a Thursday and I
want to approach it from a
couple of different angles.
One is by just showing you
a series of pictures, uh,
which you might recognize and talk about
why this is an example of biomedical
engineering.
And so this is one that probably you all,
you all know what it is when you see it.
It's a familiar looking image.
It's something that probably we all have
some personal experience with, right?
This is a chest x Ray, uh, that would
be taken in your doctor's office,
for example, or a or a radiologist's
office. And it is a, a,
a good example of biomedical engineering.
And that it takes a physical principle.
That is how do x rays interact
with the tissues of your body.
And it uses that physics,
that physical principle to develop a
picture of what's inside your body.
So to look inside and see things that you
couldn't see without this, uh, device.
And, uh, you'll recognize some
of the parts of the image.
You can see the rib cage here, the bones.
You can see the heart is this large,
uh, bright object down here. If
you're, um, if you're, um, uh,
have good eyesight from the
distance that you're at,
you can see the vessels leading out of
the, out of the heart and into the lungs.
And the lungs are these darker
spaces within the rib cage.
And physicians over the years of having
this instrument have learned how to be
very sophisticated about looking at these
pictures and diagnosing when something
is wrong inside the chest of,
for example.
So this is an example of
biomedical engineering,
one that is well integrated
into our society.
To the point that we've probably all
got a picture like this somewhere, uh,
in our past and where we understand the
physical principles that allow us to,
to use it.
We've gotten over the last
two decades in particular,
very sophisticated about taking
pictures inside the body,
allowing doctors to look inside the body
and predict things about our internal
physiology,
uh,
that they couldn't predict just by looking
at us or putting their hands on us.
And this image on the top here
is another example of a, uh,
of an imaging technique.
This is a positron emission tomograph
or pet image and is taken by using
radionuclides and injecting them into you.
So radioactive chemicals that interact
with tissues in your body in a specific
way. And you can see where
those radioactive chemicals go.
And it allows us to look not just at the
anatomy of what's going on inside your
body like an x ray does,
but to look at the chemistry,
the biochemistry of what's
happening inside a particular
organ or tissue in your
body. In this case, these
are pictures of the brain.
And this has been an exceptionally
important technique in understanding how
molecules like neurotransmitters affect
disease and how they change in certain
disease states in people.
And we'll,
we'll talk about this as another
example of biomedical engineering.
This advanced methods for
imaging inside the body. Well,
this third picture you can't
probably see too much about,
but you probably recognize what it is,
right? What, where was this picture taken?
What kind of a space was it taken in?
Um,
somebody said, oh, are are operating room.
And that's right. This is a picture in,
in an operating room and operating rooms.
If you went into any operating
room around the country,
you would see lots of examples of
instruments that are used to help, uh,
surgeons, uh, anesthesiologists, uh,
to keep the patient alive and healthy
during the course of a surgery.
And this particular one, uh, down here,
this portion here is a heart lung machine.
And this is a machine that can take over
the function of a patient's heart and
lungs during the period
when they're undergoing open
heart surgery. For example,
if they're having a coronary artery bypass
or they're having a heart transplant,
then there's some period at which their
normal heart, their heart is stopped.
And this machine assumes the functions
of their heart. And this is an,
I think an obvious example
of biomedical engineering,
building a machine that can replace
the function of one of your organs even
temporarily. For example,
uh, during an operation,
this is another familiar picture.
It I purposely picked one that looks sort
of old fashioned compared to the usual
way you see this,
which might be on the nightly news.
You see a bleep going across the screen
to indicate that they've got their
finger on the pulse of what's happening.
Or you see it at TV shows like er, uh,
you see these images on
computer screens all the time.
It's an example of an EKG or
ECG and electrocardiograph.
It's a machine that also looks inside
your body but looks inside in a,
in a different kind of way rather than
by forming an image or a picture. Uh,
you put electrodes on the surface of
the body and measure the electrical
potential as a function
of position on the body.
And it turns out that the electrical
potential or electricity that you can
measure on the surface of the body
reflects things that are happening deeper
inside,
like the beating of your heart.
And if you put the electrodes in the right
position and you measure in the right
way,
you can detect the electrical activity
of the heart and record it on a strip
recorder like this one shown here
or display it on a computer. Uh,
and so this is another example of,
of biomedical engineering where you can
look at the function of a heart in a
living person and a physician
who's experienced it looking
at fees and a machine
that works well with those two things,
you can diagnose a lot of things that
are happening inside a heart and we'll
talk about that about
halfway through the course.
Okay.
This picture might be
less, uh, familiar to you,
but you probably all know that we have
developed over the last hundred years or
so,
the ability to take cells out of a
person or sells out of an animal and keep
those isolated cells alive in
culture for extended periods of time.
So this technology is called
cell culture technology.
We're going to spend quite a bit of time
talking about it during the third week
of the course and uh,
by taking cells from the skin,
for example,
or sales from your blood or cells from
the bone marrow and keeping them alive
and culture.
We've been able to study how human
cells work and learn a lot about the
functioning of human organism.
We've also learned how to
not only keep cells alive,
but in certain cases make them
replicate outside the body.
So maybe you could take a few skin cells
and keep them in culture in the right
way and replicate them so that you get
many millions of stem cells after a piece
of skin cells after several weeks or so.
Now,
one of the new technologies that's
evolving that we're going to talk about,
uh,
in the last half of the course is taking
cells that have been propagated in this
way outside the body and encouraging
them to form new tissues.
And this is one example of that.
This is actually artificial skin.
It's in this petri dish. Here is a
thin membrane. It's a polymer scaffold.
And on that polymer scaffold,
scientists have placed some skin
cells and they've allowed it to grow.
And if you maintain it in the right way,
this polymer scaffold together with
the skin cells will grow into skin.
And you can use this tissue engineered
skin to treat a patient who's had severe
burns, for example, or a diabetic
who's developed ulcers that won't heal.
And so this is an example of a
technology that's just emerging now.
It's certainly going to
impact you in your lifetime.
And we'll talk about how it works
and what the, uh, what the, uh,
what the current state of
the art is there. This, uh,
device held here is, uh, really, uh,
made of mainly plastic
and a little bit of metal.
It's a fully implantable artificial heart.
And it was introduced about a
seven or eight years ago now.
It was implanted into the first patient,
uh,
a gentleman in Kentucky and he
stayed alive for a period of time,
uh,
with this device replacing his heart and
a development of an artificial heart.
Again,
another example of biomedical engineering
is something that people have been
trying to accomplish for decades now.
And this is the closest that we've come
and there are many advantages of this
particular artificial heart and it's,
and it's an important innovation in, uh,
in several different ways.
And we're going to talk about this whole
science of building artificial organs,
uh, devices that are made out of totally
synthetic components to replace the
function of your natural organs.
And the artificial heart is
a good example of that. Well,
this picture on the bottom here is a
really just a series of colored dots.
Um, some are yellow, some
are red, and some are green.
Does anybody know what this is?
You've seen pictures like this.
Okay.
It's,
it's an example of a technology
called a gene chip that allows you to,
on each one of these spots,
there is DNA for example,
that's specific for a
particular gene in your, um,
in your genome,
in the human genome for example.
And by incubating a small sample of
fluid from a patient on a gene chip like
this, where every one of these
dots represents a different gene.
You can see by looking at the
pattern of colors on this chip,
which genes are being expressed and which
genes are not being expressed in that
particular individual.
So it lets you do a profile of not
just the genes that you possess,
for example,
but what genes are actually being used
to make proteins in the cells that
surround the fluid where
this was collected.
And so this has been a
remarkable innovation.
It's another example of
biomedical engineering
technology that allows us to look
at what's happening inside an individual,
a patient in a totally different way
than we were before by looking to see not
just what genes you carry,
but what genes are being used at
particular times in your life. And,
and this is mainly a research tool now,
but there's lots of reasons to believe
that this is going to change the way that
a physicians practice medicine by allowing
them to diagnose or predict what's
going to happen to you in ways
that they can't currently.
And so we'll talk about technologies
like this, where they're at,
what the scientific basis of it
is and how they might be useful.
Okay.
This is an airplane. What does that
have to do with biomedical engineering?
Well, you could stretch
it and say that, say it.
An example of engineering to improve human
health is getting them from one place
to another. Uh, but that would be more
of a stretch that I'm going to make a,
but it turns out that technologies like
airplanes which were developed in the
last century have become integral
parts of medicine. Uh, for example, uh,
you all know that some,
the only treatment for some diseases
is to get an organ transplant.
So a kidney transplant or a liver
transplant is the only life extending,
uh, intervention that can be
done for some kinds of diseases.
And transplants require donors.
And the donor organ is usually not at
the same physical location that the
recipient is.
Right?
And so jets like this one have become
very important in connecting donors to
recipients. A team of surgeons is working
to harvest and Oregon at one site,
while another team of surgeons is working
to prepare the recipient at another
site. And the Oregon has flown
there. Now why does that happen?
Because you have to get the Oregon
from one place to another fast, right?
The Oregon has to get from one
place to another very rapidly,
and this is the fastest way to do it.
Well,
what if we could develop ways using
engineering techniques to the extend the
life of an organ so it didn't have
to get where it went so quickly,
then that would open up lots of more
possibilities for organ transplantation
than are known now.
Or what if we could figure out ways to
avoid organ transplantation entirely?
What if we could just take a few
cells from that donor Oregon,
shipped them to the site,
grow a new Oregon at the site,
and then implanted there.
And these are examples of biomedical
engineering of the future that expand on
what we currently use,
which involves to no small
extent technology like this.
Uh,
I would guess that probably 30 to
50% of you do this every day. Uh,
you put a piece of plastic
that's synthetic piece of
plastic into your eye. Uh,
yeah.
To improve your vision and contact lens
technology has changed dramatically from
the time that I was born to the,
to, to the time that you were born.
And the contact lenses you use today are
much different than the ones that would
have been used 30 years ago. And this
is biomedical engineering as well.
Engineers who are developing new
materials, materials that can be,
if you think about it,
there's not very many things that you
would want to put in your eye and that you
would feel comfortable putting into
your eye. So this is a very safe,
a very inert material.
What gives it those properties?
What makes it so safe to put in one of
the most sensitive places in your body?
Sort of in contact with your eye?
Why do you have confidence putting it in
contact with one of the most important
organs of your body, uh, because
you trust biomedical engineers, uh,
to have done a good job in designing these
things. And we'll talk about how, uh,
bio materials are designed and tested
and what makes a material the properties
of a material that you could use
as a contact lens. What are the,
what are the properties
that it needs to have?
Oops.
Uh,
this is an example of an artificial hip.
We've learned a lot about the
mechanics of how humans work as,
as organisms over the
last hundred years or so,
how we work as sort of physical objects
that have to obey the laws of physics
that you know about.
We live in a gravitational field and
that affects our day to day life.
And if you have a hip pain or a
hip that's diseased in some way,
and you can't stand up against that
gravitational field in the same way,
that severely limits what
you can do in the world.
And so biomedical engineers have been
working for many years on how to design
replacement parts for uh,
for uh,
joints like the hip and the artificial
hip is the most well developed of those.
We'll talk about this in some detail and
you can imagine that there that there
are many requirements that a
device like this has to make,
has to meet in order for it
to be a good artificial hip.
And we'll talk about those and how the
design of these has changed over the
years in what we can expect in the future.
And lastly, up here is a picture of a,
of a much smaller device.
This is actually a,
an artificial heart valve that is made of,
of plastics and metal and can
replace the valve inside your heart.
And um, valvular disease is
not uncommon in the world. Uh,
we'll,
we'll talk about that a little bit.
We'll talk about how your normal valve
function inside your heart and how your
heart couldn't work in the way that it
did if it didn't have valves that were
doing a very complex operation many,
many times a day.
And then we'll talk about how you can
build something to replace a complicated
small part in the body like that.
Yeah.
Well let's take a step back for a minute.
That's sort of one way of looking at
biomedical engineering by looking at sort
of the things that you know about that
have been the result of the work of
biomedical engineers and talk more
generally. So what is engineering?
What do engineers do?
What makes engineering different
than other fields of study?
What makes it unique so that we have a
school of engineering at Yale that's,
that's separate from
science and the humanities.
Any thoughts?
Yeah,
it's much more hands on you.
You're actually in the [inaudible],
they're doing things I,
and many of the things I showed you where
things that were built right that were,
that were built from, uh, parts.
That's a, that's a good description.
What makes it different from science?
Science can be hands on.
We might be down at the lake,
you know,
picking up algae and studying
them or something that would,
that would be kind of hands on.
But what's different?
What would make you an engineer?
Yeah,
that's in here.
You design.
So scientists observe and try to
describe an engineer's tried to design.
They take those descriptions and that
science that's known and they try to
design new things.
And so if you look at a dictionary,
it has words like this that
you're designing things.
Or another way to say that is that
you're trying to apply science.
You're looking at applications.
So we're trying to take scientific
information and make something new.
And the other thing about it is that you
could make lots of things that are new,
but generally you think of engineers
is making things that are not just new,
but they're useful, that they do
something that needs to be done, uh,
and that they do something
that improves life, right?
The quality of life of people.
And so here's a brief and a very biased,
a history of engineering.
It's short. Uh, but, um,
engineering became a discipline and
about the middle of the 18 hundreds,
lots of universities started
teaching engineering as a discipline,
including Yale in 1852,
around that time, uh,
this might've been the first course
that was offered in engineering in the
country, was taught at Yale in, uh,
in civil engineering in 1852. And,
and even Yale students don't know this,
what a long distinguished history
of engineering that they're,
their own institution has.
In fact,
the first phd degree in engineering
was awarded to a fellow named j Willard
Gibbs at Yale in 1863 for a thesis he
did on how gears work or something.
I forget exactly what the details are,
but have you heard of Gibbs
is a name that rings a bell.
Where'd you hear about Gibbs from?
Sorry.
Yeah, g Gibbs. Free Energy.
That annoying concept that you had to
try to master in chemistry at some point,
but, but Gibbs is really the, the father
of, uh, of, uh, of, uh, modern, uh,
physical chemistry. And um,
and uh, was one of the most,
uh, um, most famous scientist
of the 19th century.
And got the first phd in
engineering here at Yale.
And then from these
beginnings, uh, engineers,
a transformed life in the 20th century.
So a lot of things started in the
20th century and became commonplace.
Things like electricity,
having electricity delivered to your home.
So you had to have ways to generate
electricity and to carry it from point to
point.
And it was engineers that did that built
bridges and roads and we couldn't and
automobiles and uh,
and so we can get from one
place to another relatively
quickly because of that,
because there are air planes that were
also developed by engineers in that
century, in that century. Uh,
we designed a lot of new materials
that could be used to build things that
couldn't have been done otherwise.
Things like steel and polymers or
plastics and ceramics and of course,
computers,
which has progressed remarkably due to
the work of engineers in your lifetime
till now, uh, you can carry
around a, a cell phone,
which would have been unthinkable,
uh, even, uh, even 30 years ago.
So a engineer's in the 20th century
have transformed our society.
One of the other things that happened
during the 20th century is that human life
expectancy increased dramatically.
People started living a lot longer.
And so what I plot on this graph
here is as a function of time,
years dates, uh, life expectancy
as a function of time.
And um, what, uh,
you'll see here is that about for the
period before sort of a 1700 or so human
life expectancy was less
than 40 years of age.
So that means a person that was born
in that year could expect to live on
average about 40 years.
That was the expected lifespan.
And the expected lifespan has increased
dramatically in the last couple of
hundred years till now. For people
that were born when you were born,
you can expect to live,
to be 80 years old,
a doubling in a lifespan,
fairly dramatic.
So what's responsible for that?
Why are people living longer than
they did just a few hundred years ago?
Well,
there's a clue here on the slide.
I indicated a couple of points here
where if we looked in the year 1665 in
London, you could ask the question.
Another way to ask the question,
why are people living so long is to
ask the question, why do people die?
And in 1665,
93% of the people that died in that
year died of infectious diseases, right?
Uh, in contrast, if you look
at a US city 10 years ago,
in 1997, for example, uh,
then people still died,
but they didn't die predominantly
from infectious diseases.
They died from other thing.
Only 4% died from infectious diseases.
So one of the reasons there's a huge
increase in lifespan is because people
aren't dying of things that
they would have in prior years.
So why the change in why the
change in infectious diseases?
Why did I focus on that one?
What makes it so much better to be alive
now in terms of your likelihood to die
of an infectious disease than
it did in London in 1665?
Yes,
but what specifically
drugs like antibiotics,
penicillin, arithromycin. Again,
something else you've probably all
had experience with and you think,
well that's, that's not
biomedical engineering. That's,
that's science. That's a,
somebody discovering a molecule that
kills microorganisms. And that's true.
It is science.
But in order for that to go from being
a science that works in a laboratory or
in one hospital to being penicillin,
which could be used all over the world,
you've got to be able to make it
in tremendously large quantities.
And that's the work of
biomedical engineers making
penicillin in the kinds of
quantities that you need so that a dose
could be available for everyone in the
world if they got infected. And
to make it, not just in abundance,
but make it cheaply enough that
everyone could afford it. Right?
So if you can make a 100 tons of the drug,
but it costs $100,000 a gram,
um,
that might not be a useful drug because
nobody could afford to use it. Right?
And so it's the work of
biomedical engineers really
to take these innovations in
science like drugs and make them useful.
Make them so that everybody
can take advantage of it.
And you also mentioned vaccines and we're
going to talk a lot in the middle part
of the course about vaccines
and the engineering of immunity.
How do you engineer what happens in our
immune system in order to protect us
from diseases? And, um,
that's another example of an area
where biomedical engineers have made
tremendous contributions.
So just to go a little bit
further with that point,
if you looked at the causes of death in
London in 1665, here's a list that I,
that I, uh, that I got from a, from
a source that was written at that.
And um, I don't even understand
what some of these things are,
but the ones in green are,
uh,
are infectious diseases there
infectious causes of disease,
a spotted fever and purples,
uh, for example, which, uh,
which we call a measles, um, was, uh,
was a significant cause of death
as well as the plague. Right?
Which we don't have any more.
Thank, thank goodness. Um,
but people died,
typically have either infectious
diseases or they died during childbirth,
or they might've died at old age, which
would have been a 50 or so at that time.
In contrast today, because we have
antibiotics and we have vaccines,
people don't die of
infectious diseases as often.
They live much longer lives and they
live, uh, to die of something else.
Right. And the leading
causes of death, uh,
currently haven't changed very much
since 1997 when this data was published,
but they die of heart
disease and cancer primarily.
Those are the number one
and two causes of death.
And we're going to talk a lot about how
one can use the technology that we have
now to treat these kinds of diseases
like cancer and heart disease.
But why do you think these are
the number one and two now?
How come these have risen above
infectious diseases over the,
over the last several hundred years?
Why is cancer one of the
leading killers in the US now,
but wasn't even on the charts in 1665?
Yeah.
Okay.
So it could be that the, that, that,
that, uh, what's your name? So,
so Justin said it could be new things
that are around and you're exposed to
stuff we weren't exposed to before. And
that's true. Our environment has changed.
The world has become industrialized,
right?
We're exposed to things that might cause
cancer where we weren't exposed to them
before. And so, um, and
so that might be a reason.
Yeah. Yeah. In 1665,
they weren't diagnosing cancer.
Right.
It was easy to tell somebody
had an infectious disease. Uh,
but you might not have known that they
had cancer at that time and they just
died and we didn't have the same methods
of diagnosis, uh, that we do now.
So maybe it was just not diagnosed then.
Yeah.
People are living longer and so now they
have more opportunity to get cancer.
Right.
The longer you live,
the more opportunity you have to
acquire a disease like cancer,
which often is an
accumulation of, of, of, um,
defects that occur over
a long period of time.
And so we're going to talk about
about a cancer, for example,
how cancer diagnosis has improved.
Uh,
what are some of the causes of cancer
and the environment around us and how can
we protect ourselves from it? And we'll
talk about treatments for it as well.
And disease. Why, why is
cardiovascular disease on the top
obesity or generally our diets are
different than they were in 1665.
Uh, we eat different kinds of things and
many people think that that's what has
contributed to, uh, to
much more heart disease.
But it could also be that it
wasn't as easily diagnosed then.
So people were dying of old age and
that was really heart disease that was
killing them. They just didn't
know. Um, uh, so there, so it's a,
it's a multifactorial.
We'll talk about that.
And I just wanted to show you this last
graph for this last set of statistics to
go from causes of death in the u
s to causes of death in the world.
To illustrate that what happens in
the world around us in the U s isn't
necessarily the same as what happens
in other places around the world.
In other places.
Infectious disease is a much bigger
part of their life and a much,
much greater risk of death from infectious
diseases and parasitic diseases if
you live in places other than the
US or western Europe for example.
And so the problem of infectious disease
prevention and treatment isn't solved
yet. Uh, we, you know this, right?
And so there's plenty of room to still
innovate in that way to develop new
methods that could protect
against diseases like aids
or diseases like malaria
that, uh, that we don't
have problems with here,
but they do in many parts of the world.
And so we'll talk about that.
I mentioned, uh, the,
the book for the course and
the book is a book that, uh,
that I've written.
It's not published yet.
And so I'm going to put chapters from
the book, uh, that are fairly final form.
And I think you'll find them easy to read,
but you don't have to buy it.
It's going to be posted on the Internet.
And I'll post chapters sort
of advance of the readings.
And if you looked on the classes server
you saw chapter one and chapter one
describes some of the sort of organization
of biomedical engineering into,
into sub disciplines,
which I've listed here.
And so we're going to talk about
thinking about the body as an,
as a,
as a system,
as a system that can be understood the
same way a motor could be understood or a
computer that could be understood.
And that study is systems physiology
and that's an important sub division of
biomedical engineering.
We'll talk about instrumentation a
little bit and I've mentioned this,
things like the EKG machine and the heart
lung machine or instruments that are
designed to either keep patients
alive or to allow you to,
um, thank you, allow you to, um,
wasn't what I thought or allow you to, uh,
to monitor their function over time.
We'll talk about imaging,
which I mentioned biomechanics
or the study of, of,
of humans is mechanical objects.
We'll talk about a field which is growing
now called biomolecular engineering.
And, uh, that is, uh,
is the design of bio materials or new
materials that can be implanted in the
body.
It's new ways of drug delivery.
It's this whole field of tissue
engineering that I mentioned earlier.
We'll talk about artificial organs and
we'll talk about systems biology or, uh,
thinking about,
um,
how to acquire information from things
like gene chips and use that information
to understand what's happening in a
complex organism like you. Now I've,
I've highlighted three
of these in blue here,
imaging mechanics and biomolecular
engineering because if you go on to study
biomedical engineering
here at Yale Anyway,
these are the things that you
might pick a to emphasize on.
These are the things that we do best
and where we have advanced coursework
available in these three categories.
And so I'm going to emphasize these three,
but we'll talk about all of these
subjects as we go through the course.
The syllabus is posted online.
I've just copied it here so you
could take a look at it. Uh,
so week one we're at trying
to talk about this question.
What is biomedical engineering?
There's some chapters here for reading
chapters one, two, and four I list,
I've only posted chapter one,
which basically reviews the
things I've talked about today.
Chapters two and four are really reviews
of things that you probably already
know something about.
So their reviews of basic chemistry,
so chemical concepts that are important
for us to all understand as we move
forward. And uh, review of, um,
of proteins and
biochemistry. Uh, basically,
so I'm going to post
those online. Uh, and,
and we're not going to talk about them
directly in the lectures, but there,
there is a resource.
So if we read about something like
Ph and you've forgotten what Ph is,
you can go back to chapter two,
which is posted and you can read about Ph.
And I try to take you through sort
of what you need to know in order to
understand the rest of
the course material.
And if you've forgotten about proteins
and what their structure is like,
you can go to chapter
four and read sort of a,
a brief review of protein
biochemistry, um, in,
in the section this week. I'll talk about
the section meetings in just a moment,
but there's no required
section meeting this week.
During this section
times I'll be available.
If you feel like you want to read chapters
two and four and then come and ask
questions,
sort of a tutorial on these topics of
chemistry and biochemistry a then I'll be
available to talk about
that during that time.
We'll start with week two talking
about genetic engineering, what's DNA,
how can it be manipulated,
how is our ability to manipulate DNA
led to things like gene therapy, which,
which can now be done in people.
And uh, so we'll talk about that.
And that's what chapter three is about.
We'll talk about cell culture
engineering during a week. Four,
how do you maintain cells in culture?
What are the limits of this?
How can you use cultured
cells to do things?
And how do engineers build new things
out of cultured cells is going to be a
subject we talk about throughout
the rest of the course.
And the chapter is listed here.
So I think that's enough.
You can follow along with the syllabus
and see sort of what the topics are each
week, what the reading assignment
is to do before the lecture. Uh,
in order to get the
most out of the lecture.
Now each week we have a section
meeting required section. They're all,
all the sections meet
on Thursday afternoon.
And the idea of the section is to sort
of amplify on some subject we've talked
about during the week and we do this in
the undergraduate biomedical engineering
laboratory in the Malone building so
that we can do demonstrations and sort of
hands on projects to really get a little
bit deeper into the subject that we're
considering.
And so in the first week we run a
section called from strawberries to gene
therapy where we talk
about DNA extract DNA.
You can play with the DNA of a,
of an organism and we can think about
how to use DNA for other purposes.
In week three,
you'll actually do some cell culture
in the laboratory and look at cultured
cells and learn how to manipulate,
do some manipulations on cells in
culture and so on. Throughout the weeks,
we have a one hour section that's
designed to give you some more detailed
experience, some hands on experience with
some of the topics we're talking about.
There are no lab reports that are due.
There's some times will
be homework assignments,
which sort of build on what
we've done during the section a,
but it's not a lab in that sense that
it's a long experience in the afternoon or
that requires any detailed reports.
Uh, but it is a required in,
I think an important part of the course.
There's a midterm exam halfway
through and a final exam at the end,
and there's a term paper which is
due near the end of the course.
So this just, uh, just say a
little bit more about the sections.
There's three sections we have online,
uh, discussion section sign up.
Has Anybody tried to do that yet?
Just so they know that it's available.
So it was supposed to be
available from day one.
You can sign up for a section that
fits your schedule. And these,
this is sort of the list of things
that we'll go through in this section.
Meetings, grading, uh,
30% of the grade is for the midterm,
30% for the final.
And so the final is not cumulative.
The final covers only things
for the last half of the course.
So it's really just like a, uh,
a, uh, covers half the course,
but it's given during the final
exam period. There's a term paper,
which I'll talk more
about as the weeks go on.
That's also worth 30% of the grade and
you'll have weekly approximately weekly
homework assignments that are,
that are, um, that account
for 10% of your grade. Uh,
but they have an impact beyond the 10%.
Because if you can do the homework
and you understand the homework,
you're going to have no problem
with the exams. Uh, so, um,
so I encourage you to spend more time
than they're waiting would suggest.
So how do you get an a? So in the
course it's very simple. Uh, you,
uh, you do the reading before
class, you come to class and, uh,
you do the homework.
And I guarantee if you do those three
things throughout the course that you'll
do well in the course. And, and I've,
I've said this almost every time I've
given the course and nobody has ever told
me that I'm wrong. And so do these
three things. If you don't get an a,
then you can come back and
talk to me about it later. Um,
the assignment for the next class
is to do problem two of chapter one,
which I've repeated right here. So, um,
and that's to think beyond
what I've talked about in
terms of what is biomedical
engineering,
uh,
to think a little bit more
about biomedical engineering
projects that you've
encountered in your life or that
you have some experience with.
And then to think beyond what information
I've given you in the chapter in this
lecture to say,
what products of biomedical engineering
do you expect to become routine in the
next 50 years?
So spend 10 or 15 minutes thinking about
this and write it down and bring your
responses to class, uh, in the next
period. And we'll talk about that.
And,
uh,
so at the end here of this first lecture
where I've gone some way and trying to
tell you what biomedical
engineering is about,
I thought it would try to relate it
in a different sort of way. And you,
you've, you've heard this, this poem,
right? London Bridge is falling down.
Everybody's heard this poem,
you played the game.
I don't know if there's video games now
if people play games like this where a
London Bridge is falling down, but,
uh, this is a picture of London Bridge.
It's an interesting bridge, which is
important in the history of London.
Bridges have really changed our society
and allowed us to get from one place to
another in ways that we couldn't
have gotten to easily before.
One of the interesting things about London
bridge is that it's now no longer in
London. It's an Arizona. You can
see a palm tree here. But when they,
when they reconstructed London Bridge,
they moved the old London Bridge
to Arizona. Some guy bought it.
That must be an interesting story,
but, um, but I just have it here.
Uh, and I think the, the, the poem tells
you something about engineering, right?
If you go through the a and the problems
of engineering and in bridge building,
we're well advanced in understanding what
are the problems with building bridges
and how do we overcome them.
For example,
one thing that could happen is that
you build it up with wooden clay.
You pick the wrong material
for a bridge and it,
it will not stand up to the forces of
nature, right? They will wash away.
And so you've got to pick the right
materials in order to build a bridge.
So you pick a better material like iron
and steel that makes a better bridge.
We know that now because we have
experienced with bridges, uh,
but still your bridge might fail.
It might fail for a different region.
It might bend and bow. That is,
it's not the forces of nature,
like the movement of the river. That's
not, that's knocking the bridge down,
but it's just the failure of
these materials over time, right?
That they don't last as long as they
might. And so you build it with a,
with a material like silver and gold
and then you encounter the problems of
society,
right,
that your bridge might get stolen because
somebody thinks they have a better use
for silver and gold,
then you're a bridge.
And I would say that in biomedical
engineering largely we're,
we're still at the stage where we're
trying to understand how things work and
how they fail and what materials are
the right ones were maybe where civil
engineering and bridge building
was a hundred years ago.
And that makes it for me a very exciting
time to study this because the problems
aren't solved in the way that bridge
building is largely a solved problem.
Now the problems like the
artificial heart are still unsolved.
There's still room for innovation,
still room to learn from
what hasn't worked before,
to learn from science and
to design something better.
And so one of by purposes of
this course is to get you,
whether you study biomedical
engineering after this,
are not excited about the subject so that
you start thinking about how you could
innovate in this area where lots of
problems are still left to solve.
So I'll see you on Thursday,
hopefully.